all right so let's talk about drugs a
little bit yeah because I think this is
an interesting place for the libertarian
or the classical liberal you basically
think that our war on drugs is
completely ridiculous
one of the worst policies ever yeah what
would be a better policy related to drew
well I think there are two things to do
the first thing is quite simply to
legalize drugs period across the board
what people do not realize is until the
1890s any drug was freely available if
you were in a chemist in Great Britain
until 1922 the United States until the
1890s you could go in you could order
opium you could order mouthing Arthur
Conan Doyle could go to the chemist in
London and get his weekly supply of
cocaine or a serious coke habit yeah
which is why Sherlock Holmes has a coke
habit in the stories so or what this
this regime we now have has been created
piecemeal since the 1920s basically so
it's not inevitable it's a specific
policy response and the results of it
have been catastrophic it has led to
incredibly high rates of incarceration
here in the United States which means
countless lives ruined and severely
damaged if not destroyed it means it's
given enormous amounts of money to some
seriously evil and unpleasant people and
led to the growth of an enormous network
of international organized crime which
would not otherwise exist in terms of
the geopolitics this is one of the major
ways terrorist organizations get money
it's a catastrophe in terms of that it's
undermined the stability of large parts
of the world like Colombia for example
increasingly that's one of the reasons
why Venezuela is in bad shape quite
apart from the incompetence of the
government net Mexico we all know
there's like a war going on in some
parts of Mexico them oh yeah so this is
an altar and it hasn't even done the
thing is meant to do which is reduce the
use of drugs where in fact actually this
has gone up right not only that but an
inevitable result of this policy is that
the suppliers and the users both go for
harder drugs because you want to get
more bang for the buck you want also to
sell and to use products that are less
bulky easier to conceal same thing has
happened with prohibition during the
1920s where the Americans went from
being a beer-drinking nation to being a
hard liquor
a nation which is not what you want to
what you want to do is control alcohol
drip right so I would say that this in
terms of its own goals this is a
catastrophic policy failure now having
said that I'm not one of these people
who is channeling Timothy O'Leary and
things that drugs are good for you that
there's no doubt there is a problem with
widespread use of drugs it's worth
saying by the way that the real problem
anyway is not least here in the United
States is the massive increase in the
use of prescription drugs the number of
people who are psychotropic
mood-altering drugs is staggering yeah
and it has grown dramatically since the
1960s so there's a more general problem
of drug use in advanced countries
particularly North America of which
illegal drug use is a subset now that am
I mistaken are you guys in Britain you
don't have the commercials we have right
are they not legal there we get with
every commercial on every especially on
cable news no yes but all of the
prescription you know that doesn't us
all out now that's just that's not
allowed under the you know advertising
regulations in the United Kingdom that
might be a regulation I before I realize
it is strange when you're watching
African and television the United States
you everything does everyone this
country's suffer from in large process
yeah you got that on cartoon cloud
following you know anyway so I think
it's what I think is that what you need
to do is to have a social movement to
address the undoubted real problems of
the drug trade which you could do if the
government got out of this and my model
would be temperance we're in the 19th
century at the start of the 19th century
on both sides the Atlantic
pretty much everyone was a drunken
stupor most difficult for me more yeah
and by the 1880s or 1890s most British
and the great majority of Americans
become seriously sober people who maybe
drink very occasionally they're not
heavy drinkers the way their
grandparents have been that is not due
to government it's due to the enormous
social movement of temperance which
unfortunately also wanted to use the law
to stop the residual 10% from drinking
if you think about smoking
okay I'm not keen on all the
anti-smoking laws we have but on the
other hand there's been a huge change in
social attitudes to smoke just made it
socially just not the thing to do to
smoke in company that's the way to
address the undoubted problem we have
for drugs is through social action
kind war on drugs he's actually making
that kind of effective social action
less likely and causing a ton of other
problems right is the smoking one must
be a tough one for you though because on
one hand at least here our taxes are
incredibly high in smoking so this is a
government so they sort of tried to
price it out of the market yeah which I
guess you wouldn't really well I don't
think they all trying to price sounds
mocking quite or they're trying to
maximize their own which reminds that
revenue which is something different
because sure a theory of these taxes is
they meant to stop you and I buying
cigarettes but actually I don't know the
US government the British government
would have a panic fit your people
stopped smoking
right they get 7 billion pounds a year
of revenue from smoking taxes right so
in a weird way they need it and exactly
Plus also they really ought to encourage
people to smoke because if you smoke you
like you to die younger you won't buy me
a whole bunch of health care benefits
and they're right but no the point about
that is that that is actually a very bad
policy because the demand for cigarettes
in tobacco products is highly inelastic
and so what you're doing actually is
hurting the poor more than anybody else
there are other ways of doing it like I
say social pressure yeah so what about
for the person so I'm pretty much with
you on the philosophical part of how the
government should deal with this and the
and the actual tangible part of drugs I
would have some concern if they just say
if heroin was a league was legal
tomorrow and and kids could just get it
at all
you look we're here in LA there are pot
stores on every corner I have a license
for it so I'm not doing something but
what do you do for the real I'm not even
talking about the Timothy Leary mushroom
stuff you know I don't Matt the really
adaptive stuff well actually me some of
the drugs that are I'd be much more
worried about things like sedatives or
cocaine that I would be heroin actually
interesting lesson of the matter the
thing is to say that drugs should be
sold legally does not mean that be a
complete free for all they would quite
clearly be regulations for example
saying that people cannot buy them below
a certain age just as we have with
alcohol and tobacco for good reason
because you you think that somebody
under a certain age which you set
arbitrarily does not have the judgment
to know whether or not they should do
this and you should enforce laws on that
very very strictly and very very firmly
you might well have a system where
certain categories of drugs or
substances you basically say well you
could do what the Swedish government
tried
home and have a rationing system there
are various ways around it the point is
it wouldn't be just a case of oh you can
walk into any store and just you know
buy your your shots of morphine and
heroin over the counter like that's
almost certainly there would be a whole
array of legislation the point is it
will be sold by a legal retailer who
would have strong incentives to have
high quality product not to sell it to
people who are going to be problematic
in one way or another because they would
have a vicarious liability under the law
for example and unlike the situation the
moment where they're being sold by
seriously dodgy people criminals are the
worst kind who actually have an
incentive to not care about who they
sell it to rather they sell it
so I'm actually if you're concerned
about protecting vulnerable people which
is what we're talking about here yeah
then actually making the sale of the
substance legal is the way to go because
it means that you're much more likely to
be able to look out for their interests
and the sellers are much less lying you
have an incentive to screw them over to
be blunt about right and interestingly
it gets back to sort of what's been the
true light here which is that a little
government involvement in a certain way
could be okay so I almost think I almost
think that my new phrase now when people
say classical what's a classical liberal
I almost think it's a realistic
libertarian do you think that's a good
way of putting it yes absolutely and I
mean the thing you say very often
limited government and smart limited
government even more so is a lot more
effective at achieving the ends that big
government Liberals wanted to have then
a big government is that's so that's a
very good reading here I think that's a
perfect way to end this it's been a
pleasure I didn't look down once that's
how I know it's a good one
for more on dr. Steve Davies you can
check out learn liberty dot org slash
speakers slash Steve - Davies thanks for
watching I will do it again next week
you